hector mejia is near spring valley with
important information from the regional
flood control district
that we all need to remember good
morning hector
hey there sherry good morning we are at
charlie fries park by
decatur in tropicana so we have this
large field where families come out here
in the evening hours they play football
they play soccer it gets crowded
but the section over here that you see
right here we were talking about earlier
this carved out section is also
a detention basin and it collects a lot
of water when it rains heavily
there are some signs up there telling
people about drowning dangers down here
with another chance for thunderstorms
today officials want people to stay
alert
with monsoon season here this is a look
less than 12 hours ago as storms fired
up around the valley
when things look dicey we're told public
works officials come out to make sure
people stay away from places like these
detention basins
and washes in case there's a flash flood
desert breeze is another big one it's
got soccer fields it's
up on durango in the in spring valley
and gowan has dog runs and a great
walking trail
up in the northwest so we have multiple
facilities
that are used for both recreation and
flood control
every one of them is marked stay out
when it's raining
do not trespass this is a flood control
facility first and foremost
washers are not supposed to have people
in them also but
as we've seen before it's a place where
some sleep
water in those can rush up to 30 miles
an hour and the regional flood control
district says they're
working to clean streets they're
cleaning storm drains if you see
anything that needs attention
they say you can give them a call for
them to go out there and fix the problem
reporting live this morning hector mejia
8 news now